what a great uplifting topic to end this
podcast I've got Aquarius and a wine
glass nobody's ever done that before wow
five weird
in a wine glass
that's how the Japanese do oh you're
drinking pukari sweat Chris what is that
no that wasn't you betrayed them that
was your vending machine downstairs the
only real problem I have with the tick
tocks covering Japan these are just flat
out spreading wrong takes about some of
the food establishments they'll be like
don't go to McDonald's go to Mossberg
it's like yeah it's like well no Moss
Burger is just worse than McDonald's
yeah Japan it's just also takes five
times longer because five times longer
than the nuggets are the only thing that
is slightly better because they use like
better chicken but everything else is
worse
oh yeah yeah but like there's some other
stuff as well where they're all like oh
if you're in Japan and you're on
vacation don't don't go to a restaurant
go to the Family Mart in order to get
this microwave pasta it's like no don't
come to the Japan and get microwave food
you have the good stuff it's cheap it's
just the image of Japan's gonna be one
where everything's crazy and ridiculous
the short size see it's always a really
wacky or wild [__] yeah I saw one that
got pushed to me the other day with like
a trillion views and it's like I went to
Japan's Teddy Bear Cafe and there's like
a [__] hole in the wall and a pool
comes out oh yeah yeah
part of the problem actually God damn it
there's more to Japan than their poor
teddy bear restaurants probably well I
just feel like Japan as a country is
just tailor made for
helps me get video ideas and sometimes
Kyle gives me some ideas that are like a
bit a bit much and uh
what's up having a conversation with
Carl she's like hey um so I have this
video idea and I'm like all right cool
what what's it it's like so you know
there's a lot of services for men out
there
um and I found one where it's for women
I was like oh okay cool like what chick
well you know there's a lot of services
where men can get pleasured but I found
a place where uh women will get
pleasured and I was like
okay so how do I what am I what am I
filming she's like well it's a massage
place but at the end the guy makes you
come and I was like how how do I film
this and she's like and I think the guy
will let you join in if you want I was
like I'm okay with not doing that yeah
and then um so I was like I'll I'll pass
but uh another guy going to it is what
you're saying or you go into it you're
using it so I would go there and film
and then apparently the customer would
be okay with letting whoever the
presenter is do the thing it's a Conor
dog video waiting ahead that's just
you're just a porn director
it's like it was and then so I I said
I'm I can't film that yeah for obvious
reasons yeah uh but I appreciate the
offer cow and it has a great sport about
it it's very funny I'm like I'm like
Kyle tell me every idea let's just go
and you know I'd rather you bring me the
weird ideas and say no then not tell me
yeah yeah yeah but uh someone else did
take up take up on the offer and I had a
chance to speak to him he's like yeah
it's a bit awkward just sat in the
corner of a room commentating while one
got finger blasted and then afterwards
afterwards she offered to let him do it
and he was like I'm okay and then
apparently her husband was just okay
with it or didn't really fully
understand what was happening right I
was like but she was okay being on
camera yeah yeah it's kind of weird I
was like all right you sound like a
brothel in Disguise what that's a half
in Japan yeah that's exactly what
happens yeah are you kidding me Japan
has so many brothels that are just
hidden in plain sight they're just there
it's insane it's actually like even the
[__] Pub that we go to you look
across the road menu
well I don't think any content I'll be
making on top of that yeah no that's so
hard
the only [__] times we're like well
when is that happening
okay we're ready I'm ready to strap over
the plane launch into a volcano what are
we skydiving
all right do you want us guys
I'll do take for guns I couldn't get him
to go on a [__] children's
that was a big gorgeous
but they're looking down 200 meters it's
a quick game yeah ggs but like rather
than make take actually make take a
forgot and I thought we were really
funny to make like a trailer for tanker
guide okay then you can have all these
action-packed moments where it's just
like you know you're walking home from
trash taste then you like kidnapped and
waterboarded or something
it's a fantasy I have so you wanna you
just wanna it's gone from like [__]
bungee jumping foot to like just like
torture yeah I just want to make a snuff
film with you
I just want to make content about all of
the films that you feel or you have just
watched
well Indiana Jones
foreign
[Laughter]
I want to do that I wanted to do it for
like April fools all right um I was
gonna make a uh like a Netflix quite
true crime thing about trash day it's
called I think I told you last a bitter
taste yeah I was gonna be like they
invited me on a trip
you have a friendly Scottish character
now and who's really well acted really
angry for sure sure it's great but
that's my girl I mean yeah let's do it
hit me up yo you're in Tokyo now in
Tokyo I have a question yeah
um you when we are on the cycle you
every single day you'd be like I can't
wait to play Resident Evil full remake
and you every day be like I've heard it
everyone's saying it's the best thing
ever made uh did you play it
I play for half an hour pizza
30 minutes it was good yeah graphically
great a lot of effort though in it it
was like find the key I was like oh [__]
you know
I've never seen you talk about a game
and you're being excited for it and I
like strategy games where I could sit
there with a like a pie and just sort of
move like oh I have a tank over there
this I mean chess yeah like I could just
sit slowly digest a pile of food and
then like have all the soldiers die Age
of Empires yeah civilization anything
like that there isn't evil people to
your to their death basically it's like
go on while agent go on man well he's my
camera bear I'm surprised you've brought
up the fact I listened to Joseph Stalin
yeah you did well so we're on the cycle
and it was very tough and Chris for the
first two days was very like hey guys
what's up and then and then I think it
got so difficult it was very tough it
was so much harder than Hokkaido yeah
and there was a lot of rain there's a
lot of rain it's miserable and then
after the we had the the third and
fourth days was hell and then after that
Chris Chris was like a hikingomori on
his style and audio books it was like it
was like we didn't hear from Chris for
the next four days he was just cycle and
then occasionally apparently because his
phone was connected to the car when he
was cycled closely to the car the Stalin
audiobook would start playing in the car
and it'd be like it would like be put on
pizza he'd be like well so guys we're
gonna go and he'd be like Stalin
murdered 15
000 people because they dropped his
handkerchief on the floor and it was
just like what is he doing what is he
what is motivating this man to cycle
what is this reason I I was listening to
start Stalin's toils and ups and downs I
thought why why
he's like for most of his life Stanley
was like living in well maybe you want
to listen to all of this on the cycle
pods I thought he's had a rough rough
time well I'm making stuff nice yeah
better off time before he became the the
Undisputed [__] Paramount leader of
Russia he was in like prison camps in
Siberia for 20 years all right and I was
listening to that thinking if he could
do that I can get through today's cycle
that's like my thought process but then
it just got really Bleak Because by the
second half the book when he becomes
powerful he's just like if his friend
says something he doesn't like he's like
yeah
it's like Stalin killed his friend David
and like every every [__] page one of
his friends just being sent off to a
concentration camp whatever Jesus Christ
just like this isn't this isn't fun but
it's still more fun than this [__]
psycho did you like it the weather was
bad the weather was the terrain was
brutal like the hokkaido's like if you
ever want to cycle for a week do Hawk I
do like that's great yeah beautiful city
it was tough it was stunning
we regularly had four 500 meters and we
had a 700 one day check back the video
of this one Hill That Never Ends it's
like if we were walking 40 minutes on a
vertical Hill I remember yeah I remember
that hill so distinctly because it just
never ended that was pain that was true
suffering but not as bad as Stalin and
there's people yeah Stalin did
um well that was Wireless to that I
think I needed to get through it
my mind
I just needed something I need some I
don't know I I had I had I had a
playlist of uh songs I would listen to
before I go like I went on stage just to
hide me up yeah like a lot of like
Carpenter brute just to be like let's
just get the adrenaline and then run it
yeah you know I I started every day so I
could listen to music the one song I
always used was uh Boogie Wonderland but
that's when I'm fine
and I'm like yeah it's so happy now
there's a bathroom though he did not
interact with Chris for the first two
hours of the morning until he's fully
woken up I need the whole Earth Wind and
Fire album yeah
that's a good track yeah it was a tough
cycle it was a tough one I think we'll
definitely change some things for the
next one yeah e-bikes
no just get a moped just get a moped
yeah because like we picked the time
where it should have where it like
didn't rain much and it was just we just
got [__] by some weird rainstorm that
come from the south it was horrific it
was horrible that one day because you're
hot and sweating like this temperature
now but you've got rain mixed in with
the sweat so you're drowning especially
when you've got your gear on you're
cycling you have to really go to a very
special place to get through that you
have to take the whole style
people are donating me like ah yes this
reminds me of my nanny Navy SEAL trailer
I'm like what the [__] I'm just trying
to cycle he's like yeah it feels awful
but you have to just keep going I was
like oh my God you know what got me
through a Stalin audiobook [__] because
there's no part of your body that's
comfortable in that it was it was like
you know you fell off twice I fell off
twice as well that was just miserable
and that looked painful yeah my leg was
awful I had to cheer you up one day yeah
because it's so nice he's cheering Conor
up because I was miserable that's one of
the stuff yeah you were like you look
like you were gonna stop or just implode
well because like I think any sane
person doing that who wasn't on camera
would just call it a day there and I
think any of us are just wouldn't you'd
see that level of rain and you'd be like
no we're not taking this yes because it
was the kind of rain where
you know if it drizzles or rains
normally you you get a little bit wet
maybe your hair gets wet your clothes
get a little bit damp but your shoes
aren't like water locked and you're not
like soaked and because you know you're
moving and it's it's constantly there
but that was the kind of rain where I
just I remember I remember so distinctly
there was this bridge that we started do
you remember this bridge it's a really
long bridge about a kilometer long and I
remember we started because it's the
start of the bridge was the start and by
the end of this bridge I was completely
soaked was soaked they were fully like
waterlogged you get every single worst
thing that yeah every single part of the
body it was 10 minutes in it was already
like your Feet's in the river tent and
then your your glasses your you can't
[__] see anything because you're you
know you've got water on your glasses or
it's just like everything's miserable
and then the worst part I don't know if
you if you remember this but I I got
really cold I started getting really
really cold uh towards the end of the
day at the point where I was like
shivering for like the past two hours
and I was like I don't know what to do
because I can't get water because to get
warm I need to dry and there was a point
drying when I'm going to threaten to
piss yourself to get warm I was I was I
was actually this close away from
pissing myself because I was so cold
right I know it was it was to the point
where I thought I was cold where I was
like I think I would have bad Health
consequences if I was out for like
another two hours yeah yeah yeah and I
think we had 20 kilometers left where I
was really feeling faint I was like
let's just do it let's just just finish
this and I'm being I thought you meant
let's just piss yourself
I was desperate so I was like I gotta do
something and I remember being in the
McDonald's afterwards just depressed
because I was so I was still obviously
even when you when you've been cold for
like a few hours yeah uh even if you
change clothes and get warm it's kind of
weird your body doesn't quite heat up as
fast
yeah yeah it was kind of weird because I
was just in this McDonald's feeling like
[__] and then I was just but Chris was
full of joy because Chris was I I
remember I remember the menu came out
and you were like well it was a good day
it wasn't that bad that day and I was
like
oh
and I just felt like [__] because we
were also McDonald's and there you got
the wrong Burger
and then they [__] up my order that
was last day but they also [__] up my
order that day as well it was not good I
can't hear you sorry Christopher Nolan
film what is he saying yeah I ordered on
the [__] app but yeah that was that
was a grueling one I think we're going
to change a few things the next one but
these are the moments that define the
year it's true it's true I'll never
forget
yeah oh yeah I know
suffering suffering is what you remember
a lot well it's not like type 2 fun
right type two fun yeah
fun in the moment it's not it's not fun
at the moment but then when you look
back on it you're like that was fun who
named it type two I don't know that's
quite good I like that because it's easy
how often have you done something that
you remember to send me my [__] right
and then you look back on it and you're
like that was fun you're like no no
Connor don't don't lull yourself into
thinking that was fun it was not fun the
idea of it again was fun and the
highlights were fun but it was [__] yeah
I'm gonna see you on your cycle like
next cycle fun it's like I'm having such
type 2 fun right now
[__] out I mean it was all worth it
to CP on a bike for five seconds yes I
can do it I believe that was so good did
well for the second one like 10
kilometers which is pretty good there's
less I didn't need to do so I was very
happy yeah life just a bunch of memories
it is yeah the weeks where I'm just
standing doors doing the same [__] the
ones you forget it's when you get out
and put yourself through hell that you
remember it right absolutely